la una oración depende de los estados
unidos normalmente es un evento de gran
celebración miles de personas llegan
aguas en el isi para mirar el documento
para participar en el desfile y para
asistir a los bailes y las celebraciones
la noche que da una versión este año es
diferente a raíz del convite y también
de las amenazas violentos a raíz del
conflicto sobre la elección
washington y si es más como un
campamento armado
el famoso nacional la zona de parques
que va entre el memorial de lincoln y el
capitolio está cerrado
los hoteles están restringidos tanto
earl bien me está destruyendo la llegada
de gente como los airbus que también
están poniendo medidas para asegurar la
seguridad de la ciudad
hay canción en la ciudad
a raíz de las amenazas contra el evento
que han detectado las fuerzas de
seguridad no hemos visto esta clase de
evento para recibir un precedente desde
que abran y que haya siglo 19 también
llegó agua sin disipar la amenaza
hay mucha esperanza para un nuevo
presidente pero el evento para decidirlo
va a ser algo muy tranquilo y algo con
mucha seguridad y protección ojalá que
este es un paso solo esta vez en cuatro
años
estamos volviendo a celebrar con alegría
de que estamos acostumbrados